SPEAKER: In Android
Studio 2.2, we've
greatly improved
the Visual Layout
Editor, including built-in
support for ConstraintLayout.
ConstraintLayout
is a great new way
to define complex
layouts without the need
for nested view hierarchies,
thanks to a flexible constraint
system.
It's available in the
Support Repository,
and works all the way
down to API level 9.
To install it in Android
Studio, open the SDK manager
and select both the
ConstraintLayout
for Android and Solver
for ConstraintLayout
from the SDK Tools tab.
To use it in your project,
add the dependency
and build a gradle.
Now, create a new layout file
with the ConstraintLayout
as the root view.
Notice that, in
Android Studio 2.2,
the Layout Editor gained
a few new features,
such as the
Blueprint mode, which
you can use alongside the
Design view if you wish.
On the right side
of the screen, you
can see the redesigned
View Inspector.
Here, you can switch between
the commonly-used View
properties, and the full list.
The Inspector also includes
ConstraintLayout-specific
layout attribute editors, which
I'll show you in a moment.
First, let's start by dragging
an image view from the palette
onto the blueprint.
You can see that every
view in a ConstraintLayout
has four handles on the sides--
top, right, bottom, and left.
Views that inherit
from Text view
also have a baseline handle.
To position views
relative to each other,
you can click and
drag from one handle
to another of the same type.
Here, I'm placing a
Text view in the layout
and aligning it to the
right of the Image view
by creating a constraint
from the left handle.
I'm also aligning
these views vertically
by adding a top constraint.
The views are still a
bit too close together,
so you can adjust the margin
by dragging the Constraint
view in Design Preview, or I
can use the Properties window
on the right.
That looks better.
The only thing that remains
is positioning our views
inside the parent container.
By enabling the Show Constraint
Settings in the toolbar,
I can see that
there are currently
no constraints pointing to
the outer edges of the layout.
My two views would
simply get moved
to position zero at runtime.
By connecting the top and left
handles to the parent edges,
I can specify how
I want to position
the views in the container.
What if I want to
center a view instead
of gluing it to the left or
right side of the screen?
I'll create a new Text view,
and center it horizontally
within the layout by connecting
both sides to the parent.
You can see the view now
has constraints pulling it
both ways.
Because ConstraintLayout
can't satisfy both constraints
at the same time, the
view remains centered.
If you now look at
the Properties window,
you can see a slider
called Horizontal Bias.
By changing the percent
value using the slider,
I can influence the
strength or weight
of each constraint,
which results
in moving the view slightly
to the left or right.
You can also change the desired
width and height of a view
by cycling through three modes--
Wrap Content, Fixed Size,
and Match Constraint.
You shouldn't be using Match
Parent in ConstraintLayout,
and use Match
Constraints instead,
which basically means
that the view can grow up
to the available
space while still
satisfying its constraints.
To remove a constraint,
click on one
of the sides of the box shown
in the Properties window,
or click on a handle
in the Design view.
You can also delete all
constraints on a single view
by clicking here, or remove
all constraints and the layout
using the button in the toolbar.
We're continuously improving
both runtime performance as
well as editor capabilities,
so always make sure
that you update to the newest
version in the SDK Manager
and your build files.
And check out our
code lab and article
on "Medium" for more advanced
ConstraintLayout examples.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for watching.
And if you want to
learn more about Android
Studio and Android development,
click on one of the videos
here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]